breaking earlier today a federal judge
ruled that
deferred action for childhood arrivals
or daca
violates the administrative procedure
act the judge
ordered the department of homeland
security to stop approving new
applications
for the time being as a reminder daca is
an obama-era immigration program
that prevents certain illegal immigrants
from being deported
well joining us now with three at four
reaction is the co-host of outnumbered
former white house press secretary
kaylee mcinerney
along with fox news contributor joe
koncha and former senior adviser to
president trump stephen miller thank you
all for joining us
here tonight this beautiful night
stephen i want to start with you
because you've been so involved and
engaged on immigration policy for
president trump what does this ruling
mean tonight
well the ruling is a huge victory for
the u.s constitution
unfortunately the judge did stay his
ruling so
it's not going to mean that the work
permits
and the government benefits this has
been given to hundreds of thousands of
illegal immigrants will be cancelled
those will continue and so the
lawlessness will continue
but on on the marriage is an incredibly
important moment for the us constitution
to say that the executive can't make
law the executive cannot give amnesty to
people through fiat
that congress has refused to give time
and time again
unfortunately this president that we now
have
joe biden has issued a number of
memoranda
that just like daca are plainly illegal
create new immigration law
out of nothing at all and my
organization america first legal is
taking this president
to court along with many of our great
attorneys general to sue over those very
policies
no this is a developing story and such
an important one
and we will continue to moderate and i'm
sure we'll be coming to you with a lot
of questions
for it but let's shift back now to what
happened at the white house
uh kaylee i want to get your perspective
you stood on that podium before but i
got to tell you
what i hear this white house doing in
colluding with
facebook to take down accounts to
monitor people some would call that
spying
it's truly stunning to me the openness
in which they admit that yes they are
doing this
you just hit on the key point which is
the openness with which they are doing
this i mean i was literally i hear a lot
of things that
in the white house press briefings i
take issue with or i know it's a
deception or
uh not a truthful matter and what's
being spun to us like saying republicans
want to defund the police but i
literally almost fell out of my chair
when i heard an admission from the
podium that they are working with social
media companies
to censor i mean this is the crux jason
of the lawsuit put forward by president
trump that class action lawsuit he says
social media is colluding with the
government and thus becoming state
actors
and trampling on the first amendment
people said oh no that's crazy president
trump that's crazy
it was admitted from the podium and then
doubled down on today and what a
very poor cleanup effort i heard
something in that sound bite about
well people care less about big brother
and more about saving lives
that's not how the first amendment works
you have free speech in this country
with few exceptions like obscenity and
child pornography and real threats
you have the ability to speak and the
government cannot compel a private
company
to censor you i think they've got a lot
of legal morass in trouble coming their
way after that press briefing
yeah the federal government joe is
supposed to be the regulator
of these this organization but they're
colluding with this organization
to take out down what they define as
misinformation now
misinformation how does the government
and facebook
the facebook gods determine what
misinformation
is precisely i like the word colluding
here because
it fits if the white house is colluding
with facebook
on what is right and wrong speech per
their definitions
then every news item deemed negative to
the administration
can also ultimately be censored or
suppressed outside of covet
now you saw jen saki before she said the
administration is simply
what working with facebook to combat
misinformation but who gets to define
what misinformation
is the white house so look one has to
believe jason
that a facebook is not biased in serving
at the pleasure of the democratic party
of course it is
and of course facebook is acting in good
faith you have to believe that
it doesn't and facebook's fact-checking
in the past in terms of having a good
track record
yeah no because remember about a month
ago if you
posted anything in terms of did covid
come from a lab
in wuhan china that was suppressed and
censored because it was deemed
misinformation and many in the media in
the democratic party
called it a reckless conspiracy theory
yeah misinformation now suddenly it's a
real possibility as even democrats are
conceding
so facebook also suppressed and censored
any misinformation about hunter biden's
laptop or remember that they called it
russian disinformation
so not exactly a shining track record
here here's your takeaway
poll after poll after poll says that a
majority of americans including
democrats
support breaking up big tech but as long
as democrats are in power
and they benefit from big tech that
ain't gonna happen jason
yeah they're carrying their water and
stephen i think one of the most
the biggest concerns that i have is now
you get these reports
and they're admitting that they are not
only going to go
and look at social media but they want
to go after your direct
messages one-on-one communication with
whoever you choose to
a suspicionless american talking to
another americans it doesn't get any
scarier than that
whether you're talking about this
whether you're talking about what's
happening on the border or daca
it's about the u.s constitution being
thrown out the window
the other two guests had it exactly
right joe and kaylee
this is state censorship creeping
authoritarianism from the left
has now reached a full gallop apparently
jen
saki did not understand the lesson from
1984
when presumably she read it when she was
in high school it was not intended as a
governing blueprint it was intended as a
cautionary tale
and to hear her at the press podium talk
about
government censorship as a positive good
is truly chilling going after americans
with the mighty power of government in
collusion with big tech
to take away their free speech to take
away their platform to take away their
livelihood
to invade their private province to
private domain as citizens their ability
to express themselves
this is something out of an autocracy
and as kaylee said it is a huge gift to
president trump
because jen saki has admitted now with
the white house seal behind her
that big tech is doing the bidding of
big
government and that makes it
unconstitutional
kaylee going into 2022 i mean if the
democrats think that it's misinformation
to
take a different policy position than
the current administration or a democrat
running in some congressional district
presumably they can either get that
taken down or have it suppressed
or have a warning label slapped on it
oh we've already seen it happen here in
florida governor desantis had dr scott
atlas a fantastic colleague
that i used to work with from stanford
there were other yale scholars on this
panel that governor desantis hosted
very well credentialed academics and
they merely talked about
children not wearing masks citing all of
the harm that it can do the world health
organization already says
small children should not be wearing
masks but when governor desantis
and stanford and yale experts said it
youtube took the panel
off the platform that is censorship
designed to do exactly what you said
censor a political rival
this will become political and i'll tell
you this they will never to joe's point
censor lies about lafayette square lies
about covid origins
they will never censor any of the lies
told about president trump russia
collusion russia bounties i could go on
and on
where is that censorship it doesn't
exist
joe you know one of the things that
strikes me too is where are all the
liberals you know the true
liberal who doesn't like big government
that wouldn't like censorship and so
they're like totally gone they've been
totally wiped off the face of the planet
they've now gone to this radical far far
left
part of the party that does believe in
socialism does believe in communism does
believe
that there should be state control but
it strikes me that
this idea of a liberal is actually gone
out the door
that's the amazing part right i'm old
enough to remember the patriot act
which was enacted right after 9 11 right
and the excuse was
the same as we're hearing from this
white house we need to save american
lives
therefore we will trample on the
individual rights
of people's privacy i didn't agree with
that then
i don't agree with that now and back
then remember that was a republican in
power
the bottom line is that in these
situations you can't use well we want to
save your life
therefore we are now going to spy on you
we are going to infringe
on what you have as privacy in order to
save you
and by the way i don't think anybody's
really going on facebook and seeing some
things that are on there and saying you
know what
i was going to get the vaccine but now
i'm not because the flu vaccine
only what 48 of people in this country
get the flu vaccine maybe some people
just don't like vaccines
i got the vaccine i'm very happy with it
i think it's very effective
my family got it but i'm not going to
judge anybody who doesn't want to get it
and i'm certainly not naive enough to
think
that because of social media that's
killing people like the president said
maybe just some people don't like to put
a foreign substance in their body
that hasn't been around for very long i
don't agree with it but i respect
their right to that opinion in terms of
what they do with their bodies jason
yeah look this is the united states of
america where
where self-determination is so paramount
i got the vaccine my wife got the
vaccine i believe in it
but you know what i respect other people
get to make their own decision
and i don't need the gods at facebook
colluding with the federal
government uh and the government
bureaucrats to make these types of
determinations
joe kaley stephen thank you so much for
joining us here tonight we really do
appreciate it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else